I want the truth who this guy really
is we have tried everything you were the
only one who gave us hope I will try my
best been trying to get an angle on this
medical piece Palo macini who's
developing artificial organs medical
Miracles the work I do this could change
the world I take a 3D printed Trum and
transform it into a living organ this is
groundbreaking work the implications are
historic perhaps you'll even bring the
Nobel
home I'm producing a special about you
your patience they really trust
[Music]
you do you trust
me where is
he just sicker than any of us he
wasn't why are you not holding him
accountable the issues are completely
unrelated to my procedure you've always
had great instincts maybe you should
trust
them I need you to look into someone for
me he's experimenting on
people I want to see it with my own
eyes my team and I have to deal with
very extreme
cases just the ones extreme enough that
nobody will notice when you kill them
history is built on lines that we must
be willing to
cross what' you do Paulo what did you do
to them we have to figure out a way to
stop this
guy she's sitting there with a bloody
time bomb in her
throat
clear welcome
back